[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream number 67 this time i don't even
need to ask you if it's 67 i'm so
certain that it is here we are
two-thirds of the way to a hundred two
i had not put that together but you're
right now that you mention it indeed all
right well that's an accomplishment in
and of itself
all right we are have a lot of
interesting things to talk about today
um we've got winter chaos out the window
there's so many of you
joining us from pacific northwest you
are familiar with what we're
experiencing
yes and those who are not we have a kind
of an unusual buildup of snow we
sometimes get snow here it usually
doesn't stick very well maybe an inch or
two in this case what we've had
is interspersed snow and sleet so
there's
ice layers and snow layers and all kinds
of things
and one could do a kind of a snow
geology or a snow archaeology on the
layers if the
uh if the um if the
earth form was different we would be
having avalanche warnings i have no
doubt that large amounts of snow would
be
sliding off into gullies and things but
you know not in the rolling hills here
not in the rolling hills uh yeah indeed
i guess uh
some uh a bunch of covers at the
portland
oh my god didn't look it up though like
not the yacht club some
some boatyard um all of the covers
collapsed
on the boats and they're presumably now
half sinking under the
under the snow so anyway that's our
situation here we're gonna start with
some announcements today
and then talk about where we're going
lots of interesting places to go today
um but first first announcement is that
you
are going to give away yes
i'm going to give away an invite to
clubhouse and i'm going to defend the
doing of that and then tell you
uh how it's going to work clubhouse is
an interesting
new social media platform everything is
audio there's actually no way to contact
anybody on it
by text everything is done in speech and
it's all ephemeral which has created a
new kind of dynamic and
it sometimes goes terribly it often goes
in a fascinating way
and the thing is it's an opportunity
these invites are highly sought after
it's still in beta
so there aren't a huge number of them
available and
this is a great time to get in on it
because it's still deciding what kind of
social network it's going to be and if
you're there you can participate in
helping to guide it so what we are going
to do
is we are going to have dr rollergator
our moderator
decide who in the chat is deserving of
an invite now i should tell you
at the moment clubhouse is iphone
one of our moderators yes one of our
moderators um it is ios only i won't say
iphone only because i think an ipad
would do too
that is not the long term plan so if you
don't have an ios device you could
get a cheap one somewhere or you could
bank your invite and then when it
uh goes on to android and other
platforms then you can use it then
so this is this is legit as as someone
who has never been on clubhouse i'm
asking you i understood it to be
somewhat
somewhat elite in some ways you're
allowed you are allowed to give away
an invite they that's legit they give us
invites
as a matter of course and we are allowed
to give them to
anybody uh we want to i think this is
completely legitimate if it is not i
apologize but i believe this is
completely within the rules all right
all right
okay so um other announcements and
you're gonna finish with uh
one but uh we had just wanted to um
remind people about one and tell people
about two more
there were three really terrific
conversations i think that went public
this week one of them
was yours with daniel schmottenberger
here on the dark horse podcast available
on youtube and on wherever you listen to
your audio only podcast you'll be
dropping another
terrific conversation next week we'll
leave who that is
uh quiet for the moment um so you know
do listen do listen to that
um i also had two conversations with two
just amazing women this week two
different conversations and i recommend
them both highly as well
one was with kelly j keane also known as
posy parker
on the newly named newly renamed
biological women's hour
you can find that on youtube at
biological women's hour and then the
second was with julian vigo
on her podcast savage minds uh you find
that on podcasts or at her sub stack
and i highly recommend both both of them
and all of the conversations
and work they're putting out in the
world and the two conversations i had
with them in particular
isn't every hour biological women's hour
uh not when it's just you having one
even then i mean female choice being
what it is it sort of seems to me like
that's the uh the law of the jungle
also born a woman and all that uh born
of woman as you point out yes
yes no in so many ways yes yep um
yes well we do live in an era in which
pointing out the obvious seems to take
up an awful lot of our time doesn't it
yes i think kelly j would be uh both of
them actually kelly j and julian would
be
um first to acknowledge that that is one
of the sillier aspects of
our modern era um also
on the discord tomorrow the discord
server which you can
get access to at either of our patreons
uh you have uh you are gonna be
on there tomorrow on valentine's day for
breakfast with brett at 10 a.m pacific
so that's just um that's just an
announcement for those of you who've
been wondering if it might be might be
worth it i think it will be
um we've also just posted a clip from
last month's private q a
so every month we have a two hour
private q a that you can access to on
my patreon and the and we're we're going
to begin
picking one clip out of each of those
maybe
and uh and making it public every month
and this one
is about it's a story of your firstborn
who happens to have been
a crocodile you're right so you will
find you can find that youtube clip
yes as you said in in the clip so you
can find that
on this youtube channel or on the dark
horse podcast clips channel
um to find the story of how it is that
brett comes to
identify as a crocodile mom
did at one point in my life at one point
yep um
and let's see oh you wanted
um because i couldn't figure out where
else this might go in today's
diverse show you wanted to say something
about
something that happened this year oh yes
um
comedian tim dillon on his show uh very
widely circulated show
took us to task and uh and truth and
advertising i have not seen this i don't
know
i know something about what you're going
to say but i have not seen the clip so
he actually took you to task oh no in
particular yes for
that uh being a cat lover deep lovely
voice of yours okay um
i'm not sure exactly what his problem
with it is but
um somehow he was impatient does he wish
i would shut up already
uh he didn't say it in so many words no
but he uh he
rather broadly uh challenged the idw
for um being uh
unable to uh take a joke
now i would yeah so here's the thing he
says that we're unable to take a joke
um what he doesn't do is say it to our
[ __ ] faces
all right that was a joke of mine um
actually i do want to
i caught you off guard didn't i i just
don't know what's going on yeah no i
just uh
i actually think that um among the
strengths of the people who are
typically associated you know idw is not
a
membership organization it has um you
know flexible boundaries and all but
i do think if you if you think of all
the people who are named
in that cluster um i think maybe
one of the few absolutely universal
characteristics is that everybody can
take a joke
right everybody there has a sense of
humor about them except
oh god the cats yeah they are
i know that i'm sure that eric would not
say that there were any cats
associated with the idw but there are
many cat owners
and the cats such as this one famously
unable to take jokes
don't get it it goes right over their
heads i i don't know that eric would
acknowledge that there are
that the cats are meaningfully
associated that was my point that's what
i said
oh right but nonetheless so there's no
you know they can take a joke or not
take a joke from
from his perspective i would imagine he
has only finally worked his way around
to accepting dogs
into the idw adjacent sphere and what a
sweet dog
yeah lovely dog all right so i think
that's uh that's basically it i would
just say hey tim
uh you want to make jokes about us just
try us and uh we'll see how we do it
taking them and returning fire
uh i look forward to it all right okay
so um oh i guess so i want to just
review some of what we're going today
before we go ahead and launch into it
but
first i will also say that um every week
we're getting a ton of communications
from people
most of which we're grateful for the
vast majority of which we do not have
time to respond to
and one of the themes that i am seeing
ramping up again as we were at the
beginning of last
northern hemisphere summer for instance
is a lot of chaos
in the diversity equity and inclusion
sphere and we're not gonna
we won't be discussing that today but uh
i i guess i want to just promise that
even though
i think it's no one's favorite topic um
who
among those who are listening to us
largely it is a really important one so
we will probably probably next week but
certainly
soon talk again about some of what's
happening in in that space yeah it does
seem to be moving
rather rapidly it's about time we uh
revisit it and figure out where we've
landed
yeah exactly so um but first no not
first
this week uh this week we are going to
spend some time
talking about sars kobe 2 origins and
what the
what the who commission has said and
why we should definitely listen to the
authorities when they tell us to follow
this science but not
that science right what the who what
what the who um and then
uh and you know that'll that'll be
drifting on various topics in that
in that space the things that i really
want to talk about this week
include how the moon affects our sleep
how fish are being affected by uh
pollution in the water supply
specifically antidepressants
and what carnival which should have
started yesterday but has been mostly
canceled most places including the
american
version of it which is mardi gras means
what its response to what its value is
and talk a little bit about our actual
history with
with carnival and and finish by showing
i've just chosen
12 13 photographs that you took when we
were able to experience carnival
ourselves in 2016.
uh so those are some of the places we'll
be going today
i have a prediction on one of these so i
don't know where you're headed with this
fish thing but i have the sense that
antidepressants affecting fish will
result in something
very very bad about which the fish will
feel better than they might
i yeah i all right we could just leave
it as a prediction
i'm not sure better i think there's kind
of a an unfortunate regression to the
mean going on
uh with regard to these mood disruptors
makes everyone more more clonish even
the fish
fish fish cloned fish
yeah exactly okay so um
you came to me this week and said with
regard to
the origins of sarsko v2 there's we have
talked about it many many times and we
have not tried to put together
a like an organized here is all of the
evidence
explanation and we're not going to try
to do that today either i don't i don't
think that a free-flowing conversation
is the right place i think that is
exactly what scientific papers are for
and there have been some some good ones
although the evidence keeps on
new evidence keeps on arising but one of
the things you specifically said to me
was no matter what no matter whether or
not
this thing emerged from a lab
or it came or it would never was inside
a lab we
are missing an intermediate like there
there is an intermediate form for which
we have
no evidence at this point and you know
it's akin
to the sort of you know missing link
talk in evolutionary biology although
most evolutionary biologists don't talk
in those terms
um but what we what we know for sure is
that there is the most closely
uh related virus that we have that says
wild virus that was collected in 2013 in
yunnan province
is not the same as sarsko v2
and what happened in those intervening
eight years yes and we don't actually
know that
ratg13 otherwise known as 4991
a interesting story in itself um but you
know
we don't know that it is the ancestor of
uh
sarsko v2 but it does appear to be a
very close
relative of it so anyway what i wanted
to do
was try i have the sense you know at
some point you hear the conversation and
you hear people reacting to things like
the lab leak hypothesis and dismissing
it and you realize
they don't even understand what is being
proposed and in fact they may be
dismissing it
because they have the sense that it is
very different than the actual
hypothesis on the table
so what i wanted to do is recast the
question so that at least we are all on
the same page
everybody should be on the same page
with respect to what it is that we are
looking for
and why and so um yes missing link is
something we are looking for that term
really does apply here we're looking for
a missing link in an evolutionary chain
and what that missing link might be is
the question so we should all be able to
see
that uh that dynamic but the first thing
to say is that it has become clear in
some of the dialogue that has gone on in
the mainstream press
in the aftermath and part of our
appearance on bill maher
that when people hear lab leak
they often assume that what is being
suggested
is that scientists built sars cov2
from the ground up that this is a
synthetic virus
and nobody sirius is arguing
for that i don't believe that i've seen
it proposed anywhere
i've seen it i've seen response to it as
if someone else had proposed it but i
actually i i
at least and maybe i've missed it but i
have not seen anyone say
i think that's what's going on or or
even i think that's a hypothesis that
deserves to be on the
on the table is something to be taken
seriously let's put it this way to the
extent that people are dismissing the
idea because it seems implausible
it actually is implausible now it is not
implausible that somebody could take a
sequence
from a living virus and
effectively generate a synthetic version
of it that is plausible
what is not plausible is that human
beings could design a virus that would
be
effective at spreading through the human
population we don't know
nearly enough right we haven't even as
far as i'm aware
gotten to the point of putting together
a protein
from scratch we cannot write a protein
that is useful maybe we could do
something structural but we can't write
an enzyme it's
far too complex for us we don't get it
yet
so to the extent that people are
comforted by the fact that it sounds
unlikely that scientists
would have constructed this virus they
are right siren scientists couldn't have
constructed this virus
but what they could have done is
composite viruses from nature they could
hybridize
viruses and make a chimera they can also
use evolution to do things that they
themselves do not know how to do
and so the core of the lab leak
hypothesis is
that serial passaging which is basically
the
acceleration of selection in the lab
using either tissues or creatures if
it's tissues it's in vitro
if it's creatures it's in vivo serial
passaging just for those of you who have
heard some of these terms right so
serial passaging and it could it could
be both right you can cereal passage in
tissues and then creatures
uh you could also what does that look
like why don't we actually get it get it
what it looks like
is you force an infection
of a creature and then you house this is
the the uh the invi
and vivo version you house the creatures
together
such that they are very likely to
transmit the virus to each other so even
if the virus totally sucks at this job
it occasionally jumps and the ones that
do jump therefore
are the ones in the population of virus
that have the characteristics that make
them more likely to jump
so if you do this enough what you get is
the accumulation of those
characteristics that make the thing
better
in jumping and it's an exact analog for
what takes place
out in the world when viruses evolve on
their own and what you've just described
is also
that in vivo serial passage ing
is a type of it's a subset of gain of
function research
right yes the purpose is to
add functionality to these things and in
fact the thing that is
best positioned to add functionality the
type of functionality it's best
positioned to add
is transmissibility right because that's
effectively
what you've done is you keep asking it a
transmissibility question rather than
for example a
how long can you last dormant on a
surface question
right so sarsko v1 uh
was it was a reservoir i don't know if
that's how actually people say it but
but lived in horseshoe bats yep and then
we believe had a spillover event into
sivits was it
it was palm civets palm civets and then
from palm civets
spilled over into humans palm civets
which are cultivated and consumed by
people
okay and mers yep um
similarly was in i don't know what bats
first
i think i believe it's horseshoe bats
although i would actually look at that
yeah for sure
and then spilled over into camels we
think we think
and then and then camels spilled over
into humans
now none of those two stories if they're
true don't involve any
anthropogenic research right there's no
there's no human research there
but effectively what selection is doing
to use the
human imposed language is that virus is
gaining
function by spilling over into new hosts
and it is not going to gain the kind of
function that we're talking about
with regard to serial passage research
as fast
because it's not being forced as fast
but you could think of for instance
that intermediate host in mars being
camels as
gain of function camels right and you
could think of those intermediate host
palm civets and stars cov1 as gain of
function palm civets
and this week peter dasik and the who
commission
decided that um we've gotten and
originally we thought we were being told
it was maybe gain of function pangolins
for stars kovi 2. and now we're being
told
ferret badgers yeah uh frozen ferret
badgers in fact um we will get back to
the frozen ferret badgers in a second
i want to put this in context okay the
thing
so it's interesting talking to people
who
are looking into the possibility of
of a lab leak we differ on what we see
as the most conspicuous piece of
evidence that points to this not having
been a natural
spillover event in part those
differences have to do with
what our areas of expertise allow us to
see most clearly
in part it has to do with different
bayesian weightings but
the thing that jumps out to to me and
many others
is the fact that the virus is so
well adapted at the point that it first
emerges
right and this is conspicuous in a
couple of different ways one
it's very much better at jumping between
people
than you would expect and there is no
diversity there's very little diversity
amongst the early
samples so what we do not have evidence
of is
a spillover event that took place in
wuhan took
months or years in order for some viral
lineage to gain the capacity to jump
well between people and then suddenly we
got a pandemic we have no
evidence of that what we have is
evidence of something that
absolutely hit the ground running right
now hit the ground running suggests an
intermediate that we don't have
right that intermediate could have been
pangolins but i must say the first time
i heard pangolin i thought
pangolin ecology does not fit this story
very well
right even if this is a plausible
mechanism you have to you know you
in order so the reason that pangolins
came up is that some smuggled pangolins
had a sars cove with an rbd
a receptor binding domain that was a
much better match than
anything else for sars cov2 now
that receptor binding domain is
key to entering the human cells
but in order to get a virus which is
overwhelmingly
like ratg13 which came from bats in
yunnan
and to get the receptor binding domain
that was found
in these pangolins you need an event
where let's say a pangolin is infected
with both things and some cell ends up
with both viruses and then there could
be a crossing over event
but it's hard to figure out how
ecologically that would happen and what
has
happened in the many months since
pangolins were initially proposed is
that the pangolin hypothesis has fallen
apart and the reason it's fallen apart
there are many different lines of
evidence but
the fact is the sars cove
that was found in the pangolins is
actually much better adapted to
infecting humans than it is to infecting
pangolins so it doesn't look like
something that was resident in pangolins
nor
are sars coves widely known to be in
pangolin so
something is very odd about or
so i'm just not clear on what you're
saying are you saying sars cove as a
shorthand for serious clothing one
or you talking about the general class
talking about coronaviruses the clade
okay so okay i think there's probably a
more precise way of referring to them
then
because that sounds like you're talking
beta coronaviruses okay
good so um in any case the pangolin
hypothesis has become
very very unlikely right in fact i would
say the evidence against it is very
strong and i was thinking about reading
a little bit from a paper that describes
why that hypothesis has come apart but i
think it's probably too
too technical and we'll we'll leave it
alone but nonetheless the point is
pangolin could have been the link
between
a bat virus which was not very well
adapted to infect humans but was very
well adapted in bats
to a virus in wuhan that is very well
adapted to humans
right except that it doesn't look like
pangolins could have been the place
where that took place so what that means
is if it isn't pangolins
the hunt is on for something right and
that something
could be a lot of different things it
doesn't have to be a critter
right it could be that a spillover event
in some
other place resulted in a
weak exchange of viruses a poorly
adapted virus jumping
occasionally between let's say people in
some other location
and eventually learning the trick of
infecting people and then somebody
getting on a train and showing up in
wuhan
and then us monitoring it and suddenly
discovering a virus that's very well
adapted to people
it doesn't say that the evolutionary
phase is absent it just says it didn't
take place in wuhan but
well but when you say it doesn't have to
be a critter what you mean is that there
doesn't have to have been an
intermediate host of a different species
than the original which is probably
horseshoe bat
or the final which is humans that's what
you mean by it doesn't have to have been
a critter right
what i'm saying is you need some sort of
intermediate
it could be a critter critter is most
likely the versions of this that we've
seen
typically go through a critter but it
could be that it jumped to people
directly and then
went through a rapid evolutionary phase
and the reason that we see no evidence
of that
rapid evolutionary phase is that it
happens somewhere else however
that's a hypothesis and it makes a
prediction and the prediction is
there's a population somewhere else in
which there will have been some
epidemiological pattern something that
will initially have been dismissed as
some normal kind of pneumonia
will ratchet up get spread better
and in order for something as well
adapted as what emerges in wuhan to show
up
there will be the late stages of that
epidemic
which will have been very conspicuous
and we would now an additional
prediction of that is that even if it
wasn't recognized as such at first
is that that population might be less
susceptible to sarsko v2 as it circles
back around and gets back there
given that we believe that there you
know there is certainly strong evidence
for at least some short to immediate
intermediate term immunity
from having had sardis cov2 and in fact
in fact this is being discussed this is
being discussed as one possible factor
it could be that something
like this virus or this virus in some
early stage circulated
in southeast asia in places that have
actually been more successful
at beating sars cove too right and so
that is one thing that has been
discussed but the basic point for us
here is
there has to be some intermediate right
this virus
knows the trick of infecting humans
extremely well
right it is it is post adaptation
where that adaptation took place isn't
pangolins it doesn't appear
it uh we don't have another candidate
that has emerged we don't have a human
population in which it could have
learned this and so in some sense
the laboratories in wuhan are one
possible intermediate right they are not
the only possible intermediate and
what heather mentioned a few minutes ago
the who in uh
collaboration with china appears to be
steering us towards
another um hypothesis now this
hypothesis
uh zach do you want to show that dasic
clip
okay so we unfortunately can't hear
the clip but you will hear i'm just
going to give you one brief
one couple minutes from this interview
between
uh becky anderson of cnn and
peter dassack of this who commission
who you will have heard us mentioned
before okay show the clip zach
well we're talking about something very
different right now
than um you know a package of um
frozen fish from somewhere else in the
world we're talking about the origins
of sars kobe 2 the covet outbreak in a
in a market
in wuhan the likely center of it the
early
spreading of that outbreak and what we
see though when we visit that market is
a place that sold a lot of frozen
products
not just the typical things we would buy
a supermarket but also
frozen animal products from animal farms
in southeast asia and inside china and
there's a really striking piece of
evidence that was mentioned today
in the press conference that in those
products were included wildlife
meat and carcasses from animals that we
know
are susceptible to coronaviruses and
also that the supply chains come from
places
um in china where we know the sars
coronavirus ii related viruses are in
other words
a direct link from the potential bat
origins of this vast which most
scientists believe is true
into wuhan market now scientists in
china tested those carcasses and they
were negative
so that's good but we don't know what
else was there
we don't really know if there were live
animals there so there's no evidence of
that but we don't know
and we don't know how many of these
animals were part of that frozen
market or even other types of meat so
you know to many of us on the team
it was a a clear clue as to what may
have happened and it was one of the
the the pathways that we thought was
um more likely than others for sure
let me just be quite clear about this
then it's one of those pathways
that might be more likely you say and
that's an agreement
uh that you made as a team but i'm
struggling
all right to understand
say again keep going then
evidence that you have to support this
contention sir with respect
well the specific evidence comes from
the work that china's been doing that
chinese scientists have been doing
from really day one of the outbreak so
around about january the first
scientists from china cdc went into the
market and started swabbing
uh the market they looked at sewage they
looked at stalls where they sold food
they looked at the stalls where the
people were positive for coronavirus
they spent about a month in there
swabbing testing
over 900 samples collected really
thorough deep
study and most of the animals products
had gone
but there were some still there and if
there were there were live animals in
the market we
we think mainly aquatic animals but we
don't know there is
there are rumors of of live mammals in
that market
but what was really intriguing was this
find of of
carcasses of animals mammals actually
ferret badgers which are a type of
animal that's widely eaten across
southeast asia which we know has the
capacity
all right so um that was peter dasak and
i we will put a link to that um that
little interview
uh on in the description of this video
you should check out the whole thing
um it's rather incoherent what i believe
is not said
anywhere is that peter dassack they say
he's a
zoologist on the who team peter dassack
is more than a zoologist he is also
head of eco health alliance which has
been
deeply involved in the funding pathway
for gain of function research
including sending millions of dollars to
wuhan to study these very viruses so he
has
an intense conflict of interest but the
go ahead
the description of him as a zoologist
across all of the major media platforms
whenever they mention him is
um is beginning to feel
intentionally misleading it is true that
he's a zoologist and that that is that
describes
uh his training from many decades ago
but what his work has been the way that
he has made a living
uh for all of his recent history is as
president
of an organization that specifically
works on gain of function research
on coronaviruses on bats um and works
with the wun
um institute so um to be clear
we are not looking to blame anybody for
the uh the covet 19 pandemic there is
fault we believe in at least the
recklessness of the gain of function
research which if it didn't cause this
outbreak certainly
could cause a very serious outbreak so
there is something about this
that requires our scrutiny but at some
level what we have
here is a failure to appreciate the
hazard of gain of function research and
that's a hazard that's a failure on the
part of the international scientific
community so
the point though is dasic has
the strong incentive to
favor any hypothesis other than
a lab leak and so the fact that he's on
the who team i believe he's the only
american on the who team
really raises the question about um
what sort of investigation this is but
the key
the key here is that you can see dasic
is very excited about the possibility
what he says
is evidence of another pathway
basically that there were frozen ferret
badger steaks
in the wuhan seafood market
and what the reason that this is
exciting
to dasek and others on the
who team is that ferret badgers
are mustelids which are another
creature which sars kovi ii can
infect so we have seen um
unlike the case with pangolins to which
stars cov2 is not well adapted
czar's kobe 2 is also not well adapted
to bats
but it has spread like wildfire through
mink farms so minks are mustelids
and the virus not only infects minks
we've seen it in effect other things
like big cats and zoos
um but what it does not do is spread
from them
the case in minks is exceptional so
minks actually
catch the disease and they spread it
very much like humans it's well adapted
to people it's well adapted
to minks and um ferret badgers is a
small
clade of closely related creatures in
southeast asia
allow me to just do a tiny bit of
phylogenetic description here so this
from
one of the the tomes of mammals it's
it's a little dated at this point um but
this is
this is the second second volume of
walkers
mammals walkers mammals of the world uh
the one that includes the carnivora
which is one
clade uh within the carnivore we have as
you have said the mustelids which
includes
broadly speaking the weasels irmans
stoats minks ferrets and pole cats
um and then also within the mustelid is
the genus melo gale
which the common name for which is
ferret badgers so you know it's not a
not a misspeaking it's neither a ferret
nor a badger although it is closely
related to a ferret and you know this is
this is true across a lot of common
names right that that you end up with
like
i don't know what it is i'm gonna kind
of call it both things and
um but both ferrets and badgers are
mustelids
so um it is it is one of the
rare cases where these two things show
up in the right clade
so yeah spotted skunks anyway it's it's
it's a cool claim skunks have been moved
out of the mustelids
not meaningfully including the spotted
skunks i believe so
okay um so i just i just had a couple of
sentences to read from walkers here
about the third badgers
also at the point that this book was
published in the 90s there were we
thought there were three
species now i think there are five you
know this is a splitter lumper
distinction that is not of much interest
to anyone
outside of the people during this work
certainly a very little interest to the
ferret badgers themselves
actually um so far um
the ferret badgers are found in wooded
country in grassland
they climb on occasion um ferret badgers
are savage and fearless when provoked or
oppressed and have an offensive odor
and a ferret badge so the diet is
omnivorous and is known to include small
vertebrates insects earthworms and fruit
and a ferret badger is sometimes welcome
to enter a native hut
because of its destruction of insect
pests
so welcome in the places where they live
which is as you say sort of broadly
throughout
south asia southeast asia so a couple
things to say
one peter dasik reports that these
things are widely
eaten um i don't know how widely they
are eaten apparently you found evidence
that they are eaten
uh by some people yeah i think let's see
the iucn red list
if i can find it here um
so the iucn um being
the what does it stand for why isn't it
on the page i don't know
um the iucn red list did suggest that
they
that the one very widely distributed
species which is the only one that is in
china including the range of uh
including within the range of wuhan does
get eaten sometimes but this is a long
okay a long payment so the chinese fair
badger okay so the point is you know
so let's put peter dasik's motives aside
peter dasik for whatever reason does not
find the lab leak hypothesis credible
and has in fact portrayed
uh us and other people as conspiracy
theorists for even considering it but
really the point is we need an
intermediate
um lab the lab would be one obvious
intermediate
in fact the use of mustelids in the lab
is likely ferrets would have been a
possible creature in which
um serial passaging might have been done
which would very well explain why this
is so easily infecting and spreading
between
minks we don't know that to be the case
but it's possible
but in any case the fact that it spreads
in mustelids means that if they can find
a mistelled link
that okay in principle there could have
been an epidemic
of the ancestor of sarsko v2
in ferret badgers in
let's say some other part of china or
some other place where they exist
and then he proposes that they could
have that in fact there was ferret
badger meat in the wuhan market he says
it was tested
negative which is good i don't know why
he regards that
as good this virus came from somewhere
and this would be as good an answer as
any if it was true
so um anyway the link would be
the frozen ferret badger stakes having
come from infected animals
where the function of infecting human
cells was gained in this intermediate
resulted in the transportation of the
virus to wuhan
where it then infected somebody in the
market or infected somebody who took
steak home from there now this
is highly unlikely for one thing
we would have to imagine if that was the
expected route
then it would have been effectively sars
co v2 that came off that stake
because if it wasn't then there would
have been an evolutionary phase in wuhan
for which we have no evidence
so it effectively has to have already
done all of that evolving at the point
that it arrives in wuhan on the stake
and what we know is that these viruses
don't transmit
effectively this way it's not to say
some viruses couldn't and it's not to
say it's completely impossible
but the idea that this came off of a
frozen stake is pretty unlikely given
how
overwhelming the transmission by
airborne and aerosolized particles seems
to be of this virus so
in any case this does have the sense of
the who team grasping at straws they
don't want to look at the lively
hypothesis for which the evidence has
gotten stronger and stronger
it's not a settled question but it is
stronger and they do want
anything else that could take the place
of that missing link in the logical
chain
and so they are now putting you know
one way to say this is frozen ferret
badger steaks are the new pangolins
all right um so just to just to wrap
that up a tiny bit more
uh zach if you would show my screen just
for a minute uh three days ago on
february 10th
nature published in their news section
major stones unturned covet origin
search must continue after who report
say scientists investigation team rules
that idea that the chronovirus came from
a laboratory leak
but offers two hypotheses popular in
chinese media
well that sub headline actually
is not an accurate portrayal of what's
in the piece zach if i might have my
screen back here i'm just going to read
from two paragraphs
lower down in that report quote another
focus of the who's investigation was the
idea that the virus leaked from a lab
a scenario that the team found unlikely
incidentally and unlikely and rules out
are not the same
peter ben embarrass a food safety and
zonoses scientist with the who in geneva
switzerland
who headed the investigation said at the
press conference that the team had
conducted extensive discussions with
staff
at the wuhan institute of virology which
has been at the center of the
speculation and similar labs nearby
he said a leak is unlikely because the
virus is not known to scientists before
december 2019.
dwyer that's a medical virologist at new
south wales health pathology in sydney
also a member of the who team
dwyer says again still quoting from this
nature news article from
february 10th about the who report
dwyer says that the team didn't say
dwyer says that the team didn't see
anything during its visits to suggest a
lab accident
quote now whether we were shown
everything you can never know
the group wasn't designed to go and do a
forensic examination of lab practice
end quote may be true
if so why not how is it that they were
going
in order to actually contemplate awe and
assess all of the hypotheses on the
table
of which there is considerable evidence
pointing to the idea of a lab leak
if they were not actually ready to let's
see
wasn't designed to go and do a forensic
examination of lab practice
who then is and so what effectively this
does
is it conflates an absence of evidence
well we weren't equipped to do
that investigation and the people who
were there say it didn't happen
right now i will say were it the case
that this virus did not emerge from that
laboratory
you would have the people in the
laboratory virtually certain that this
had not
been on their watch they would sound the
same way they do which is part of why
you can't look at them and say listen to
how they sound
that's evidence they would sound the
same either way well
they would sound the same and i believe
the the the strong implication is that
they would behave
very very differently now nobody knows
what goes on inside you know internal
chinese
government discussions of these things
but the fact is the behavior of the
laboratory has been incredibly
suspicious it has been the opposite of
transparent
and under normal conditions you would
imagine
that were you to run such a lab
you know uh zhang li herself
says that when this virus first emerged
he didn't get a wink of sleep
for fear that it had escaped from her
lab right and then she reports uh it
didn't and therefore i
you know relaxed but the point is she
considered it plausible
right were you to find yourself in this
situation where you knew that it didn't
come from your lab because you'd never
seen that sequence before
it's out in the world it's doing
trillions of dollars of damage to the
world economy and killing millions of
human beings
you would be very inclined to show
your books and say didn't come from here
take a look right even if that wouldn't
be your normal impulse because
everything is riding on this question
including the future of this lab so the
idea that they would want to keep
you know so in any case what i'm
what they did was delete a major
database
which would have contained likely
contained evidence they haven't shown
notebooks they haven't opened their
freezers the who
commission says lab leak very unlikely
but of course we're not in a position
really to have done that forensic work
right and the spokesperson from the who
team not the leader of it but the spokes
the the main media spokesperson darling
is directly tied and funding the
research that was being done in that lab
right so in any case all of this again
raises the specter of can we just please
have an
open investigation every hypothesis on
the table including
frozen ferret badger stakes that's a
hypothesis but at this moment what that
is is a hypothesis with no evidence
like the sum total of the evidence for
that hypothesis is
ferret badger stakes were apparently
present and tested negative
right you know i i don't know why i'm
sure that
that dasek wasn't thinking this but
whenever you say frozen ferret badger
steaks
i imagine one with a stick i imagine
actually a fair uh frozen ferret badger
popsicle
and um you know maybe maybe you're more
inclined or more
likely to get the virus by licking a
slowly thawing
for frozen ferret badger popsicle than
you would be by frying it up and
i think maybe you do both actually maybe
you you
you lick the frozen ferret badger
popsicle until it thaws and then you
fry it and then you eat it still i think
it's unlikely to transmit that way i
think you would have to
you would have to shave it and make
particles which you sort of
oh aerosolized frozen ferret badger
steak popsicles
yeah or snow cones no i mean actually
that sounds pretty parsimonious to me
yeah
yeah yeah the whole thing is uh is
rather rather remarkable
but hey we've got a number of
you know did it evolve somewhere else
that's a hypothesis right it's a
hypothesis that involves a train it
makes a prediction there's a population
somewhere else that had an epidemic that
we haven't found yet in spite of the
fact that
the entire world is looking it's looking
like we're all looking right yes um
did it start in um ferret badgers
who were then transported maybe live
maybe that's what happened
live to the muhan seafood market and
they coughed on somebody and we have no
evidence of it
because before being turned into ferret
badger popsicles well
here's the thing they've got the frozen
steaks you and i regard the likelihood
of frozen steaks that's pretty low
because the stuff the likelihood of them
having
passed this having passed it on that way
but there were also live animals in the
market
he waffles over whether or not there
were any live ferret badgers but
um nonetheless let's say okay the
hypothesis that it was fair at badgers
in some other part of china
that is a viable hypothesis right what
does it predict
it predicts a population of ferret
badgers who
a probably are still circulating this
virus we should be able to find them
right b will show uh
you know immunity to it in other words
we'll be able to see that they have
antibodies to this very thing
so in any case we could probably come up
with a dozen predictions from that
hypothesis well let's go to it that's
the hypothesis on the list but so is the
lab
right so anyway that's how all of this
should be should be dealt with we're
looking for a missing link we should all
agree on that
that missing link can be anything from a
laboratory to a population
of mustelids and all of these things
make predictions that's the nature of a
hypothesis
and a proper investigation would simply
sort through these things and at the end
of the day
we would very likely get the answer but
we're not going to get it by
saying you know that hype there's no
evidence for that hypothesis why is
there no evidence because we didn't look
for evidence
okay that's not well to the degree that
we looked for evidence we asked the
people who would have the most to lose
if that hypothesis were true and they
said it isn't true and so we said okay
we trust them don't you trust them how
dare you not trust them what are you
cynophobic
yes come on right exactly okay
good well i think i think we covered the
topic i think i do too hopefully that
um makes it clearer why the discussion
is moving in the direction it's moving
and what is really at stake in the
various claims
yeah okay just a little bit more on
covet though
okay because we've got we've got a
section that i have attentively titled
here follow the science but not that
science you fool
um so we have uh published this oh
actually i guess
a little over a week ago um a wall
street journal
opinion piece and op-ed you can just
show it very briefly here zach
called the universal vaccination chimera
tools for stopping variants are limited
and like masks and distancing
vaccines are not a panacea by a guy
named joseph
a ladapo who is an associate professor
at the med school ucla
uh so i came to i just in the last week
i
found this because he and this piece
were
being discussed as if he was an
anti-vaxxer and increasingly i distrust
the assessment that someone is an
anti-vaxxer just like i now distrust the
assessment someone is a racist or a
fascist or alt-right or a nazi or you
know transphobe or
any of these ridiculous epithets that
are used to shut down discussion
and sure enough this piece is not
anti-vaccination
at all it is saying basically um
that um we need a
multi-pronged approach to deal with this
pandemic and that masks are some of the
solution
and that uh distancing or some of the
solution and that vaccines
are not going to be a magic bullet a
panacea in his language and so just to
read
and you don't have to show my screen
here zach although i guess you could
have now
the last two paragraphs of this wall
street journal op-ed
are other forces pushing mortality lower
the cdc estimates that approximately 83
million americans contracted covet 19
through december
reinfection risk is low for at least six
to nine months following infection
and just taking out of not quoting
anymore
six to nine months because that's how
long we know that's that's the
that's the length of time that we have
data for this at this point so you know
in line with our earlier discussions
about vaccines where we really really
really hope these mrna vaccines are
awesome that they have long-term safety
but we cannot know yet
similarly we cannot know about long-term
reinfection risk for
coping 19. to continue quoting from this
wall street journal
op-ed from february 4th ladapo says
there is also growing scientific
evidence for outpatient therapies such
as ivermectin
colchicine fluvoxamine and the
politically charged hydroxychloroquine
as well as better hospital practices
a sharp decline of mortality will give
rational thinking a bigger stage
allowing schools to reopen and social
and economic activities to resume
it will also liberate american society
from the fear-fueled decision-making
that has dominated the pandemic response
which isn't that again what we should
all be looking for
here a reduction in fear which is
fueling
a just insane level of incoherence in
terms of the policies that we are seeing
so
two two pieces of evidence from this
week about the ridiculosity
yes the ridiculousity of the responses
that we're seeing
here we have zach if you would show
briefly from february 10th three days
ago
uh officers at dorm's outdoor exercise
ban
this is a terrible headline uc berkeley
extends dorm lockdown with stricter
mandates
so the message here is okay this is a
terribly headlined article zach if i may
um so i can see my own notes
on this um uc berkeley you know the
one of the shining jewels of the uc
system um
has banned solitary outdoor exercise
in order to tamp down the pandemic i
guess
but that means people are now locked in
their dorm rooms with circulating air
that they are sharing with other people
yeah it's almost certain that that
policy will do
harm to some people because some hours
that would have been spent not in close
contact with others
um will be spent in
encapsulated with them without getting
any fresh air without getting any
exercise without seeing any other human
beings perhaps without making vitamin d
so this is absolutely going to interfere
this is actually going to make people
sicker would be my prediction yes
and just the second piece of
ridiculousity
in terms of how how efforts are
proceeding to affect behavior
i'll set this up by saying um
increasingly when i'm
out on walks even if i'm not
within six eight ten twelve twenty feet
of people
um and i have my mask in my hand clearly
ready to put it on if i do have to be
close to people
um i am you know i've said this for
months now but i get you know i get the
stink guy from people for not actually
being outside wearing a mask and you
know it's winter here it's actually
really wintery here right now and uh i
want
it's it's healthy it's not just i want
but it is actually healthy for me and
everyone will be healthier if
they get exposure to the actual elements
on their
skin and in the winter your face is one
of the few places that you can get that
so
um why are people so confused i mean in
part it's because people feel
virtuous and on the right side of
history
for yelling at other people for not
wearing masks this is this is
unfortunately the landscape we're in and
it comes from a place of fear
and confusion but that doesn't make it
any easier to deal with so this week i
received
um the oregon coronavirus update
um again on february 10th and zach um so
this is just the web version of it so
that
um so that you guys don't see the actual
email but it's the same thing campaign
reminds us masks save lives
here's one picture cindy is a wildland
firefighter from southern oregon she
wears
masks to protect her she wears a mask to
protect her crew from coven 19.
just like she protects oregonians from
fires i don't see anyone else in that
picture but
whatever i'm not going to focus here
this seems likely to not be the thing
that is
uh necessary here but if you know with
her crew sitting in close quarters
okay but the next picture here is ethan
is a rancher and pro bull rider from
eastern oregon who wears his mask that
we can
so that we can return to normal life as
soon as possible and this picture for
those of you listening and not observing
is a vast sort of
eastern oregon chaparral scape um
endless rolling hills for as far as the
eye can see
one person on a horse no other people no
other horses no
other anything that might be
transmitting this virus
and this guy is wearing a mask and we
are being shown this picture
as evidence of how much he cares about
us
and as evidence that this is going to do
anything
to reduce transmission of covid i've
looked
i may have missed it please please
please share it
with me somehow if there is
new evidence that any of these new
variants or even the older variant can
spread outside
we covered in i think april the evidence
that was already out at that point
extensive evidence that this virus is
not transmitting effectively outside and
certainly if there's no one around where
could you possibly be getting it
right why why are we getting this insane
advice
it is about widespread behavior control
i don't i don't frankly care if it comes
from a place of really feeling good
about trying to help people and just
being really confused
the effect is widespread behavior
control and those of us who are not
interested
in behaving in ways that confused
authorities tell us to do
are now occasionally getting yelled at
by our neighbors when we are outside
actually getting the wind and the sun on
our face so
what's driving me crazy about this is
that
the advice is low quality
and it has this kind of defect to it
where the assumption is
well it can't hurt right right
exactly and the answer is of course it
can hurt right to the extent that people
are being driven crazy by lockdowns and
don't want more of it
you want to give them as much of a
reprieve as you can to the extent that
outdoors when you're not near other
people
is safe then the point is hey take your
mask off the official advice ought to be
when you are not around other people
outdoors take your mask off
right and if we should put it on when we
pass each other on the trail even though
there is frankly no evidence that that
is dangerous
okay but um you know look the model that
we built up
was it doesn't seem to transmit outdoors
that gives us
a loophole that we can exploit for
better psychological health greater
vitamin d
creation all of those positive benefits
right
we ought to protect it because it could
evolve
to transmit outdoors it's one of the
things that i would actually expect and
the way to prevent it from doing that
is to actually be more cautious than we
should be
put masks on when we're you know
standing in the ski line or whatever
even though there's no evidence that it
transmits in in those circumstances and
it didn't seem to have that that
evolutionary move did not seem to happen
in the wake
of the massive regular protests from
last
northern summer right but in any case a
rational
course would be the place where we know
you're safe is when you're not around
other people
outdoors and not around other people
might mean 12 feet away right
right 12 feet away you can afford to
have your mask down and not you know
scowl at the other person for
you know not wearing a mask whatever it
is we can afford that reprieve the risk
is really really low
as we get closer where it's more
plausible that something could
jump we should be protective of the
loophole so that it doesn't disappear
on us but we should not pretend that the
point is i'm actually exposing you
to you know a risk just because we're
standing near each other outdoors so
the policy is just i'm also i'm sorry i
interrupt you but like i'm also really
concerned about caving to other people's
fear
i and you know the fear is being
generated and
and curated and augmented by
by government officials frankly and by
you know these
government officials at the state level
and at the federal level and i assume
elsewhere in the world as well
but then you have a populist that is
increasingly just
fearful and disregulated and can't
remember what normal was
and is frankly having an ever harder
time imagine that normal will ever be
back
and in those conditions especially
really anytime
but in those conditions especially i
don't
i think it's actually even more
dangerous to say i get that you're
scared i will just
let your fear drive our behavior no
that's like that's the mistake of
safetyism on campuses
of trigger warnings of all of the stuff
that created a whole
dysregulated unable to figure out how to
move forward in the world popular
uh generation of sort of you know the
second half of
of millennials and you know again just
caveat
we happen to be teaching college for
like the entire millennial generation
and almost to a person the students we
met
didn't need that stuff they didn't ask
for it and when we said that's not
what we're going to do we are going to
treat you with respect and we're going
to challenge you i'm going to show you
things that you don't like
and that challenge your preconceived
ideas and we're going to expose our
biases and your biases and all of that
and guess what people actually ended up
educated and less fearful
and more capable in the world and why
the hell
are we asking an entire really global
population
at this point to fall prey to the same
garbagey
garbagey ideology that is clearly
causing higher ed to fail
well and at some level to the extent
that we push
nonsensical and by nonsensical i mean
doesn't match the
empirical evidence mask policy
we're going to cause rebellion against
it you don't want to give
people who are anti-mask for example
more of a point than they should have
and to the extent that you're advocating
things that don't make sense um
you're doing exactly that now i got
taken to task this week
i tweeted something i never know which
tweets are going to take off but this is
one of my
most popular tweets ever though i did i
expected it to go
not very far my tweet was something like
um if double masking uh
is that much is so protective why aren't
they built that way in the first place
now this was an honest question right
because a
i don't buy that double masking is good
that does not mean
that there are not combinations of masks
that would be better but here are the
questions that immediately arise in this
context
okay kovid is a is transmitted it's a
respiratory virus it's not it's the
reason that we have
masks for uh the protection of
people in the context of respiratory
viruses is
covid different in some way that two
masks are good for covid and not for
other things that are transmitted this
way in which case that's interesting
but i want to see that i want to say oh
we've been making masks wrong the whole
time
lots of people have been getting sick
even though masks were used because the
mask should have been twice as thick
and then we should make them twice as
thick go ahead
uh so my my only rejoinder to you and i
think we did this over the dinner table
in fact
was the one reason the one analysis that
i have seen
for the conditions under which two masks
might be better than one well i guess
two
one is that the mask that you were
wearing was a low quality mask to begin
with
and in order to make a single high
quality mask you just want to double up
two low quality masks they're low
quality in different ways
okay great also why don't you just get a
high quality
mask so like that's that's one answer
and for
um you know for me i'm wearing these
masks that my mother is making thank you
and they're they're wonderful and they
have two layers of cloth and they have a
layer
of of additional i can't remember what
the specifics are mom
um you know of additional stuff in
between the two cloth layers and they
fit my face really well
and they're comfortable and they're
awesome and you can't tell by looking at
it that it's not just a
cheapo single cloth layer mask and
that's maybe unfortunate but i know that
i'm walking around when i'm masked and
it is you know every time that i'm
around strangers and
anytime i'm indoors it's not our home um
that i'm wearing a single high quality
mask
the one the one place that i see
even if you've got two high-ish quality
masks
is that if they fit your face
somewhat differently and each of them is
a slightly imperfect fit
that potentially having the mask that
fits better on top of the mask that fits
worse can basically help
it conform to your face better that's
great then we need to then we need the
information to be given to you so that
you can figure out whether double
masking is better because here's the
problem okay
if two masks are better than one are
three masks better than two
are four mass better than three right
there will come a point i
guarantee you there will come a point at
which extra masks
start working against you because what
they do is reduce the ability of air to
transmit through them so it will go
around
now my point would be if you take a high
quality mask that fits you
well and you layer another high quality
mask on top of it you are probably
reducing its effectiveness therefore it
is not
true that two masks are better than one
it's true that some combinations are
better than a single mask of some type
right but without telling us that
saying actually double masking might be
a good idea right
you are going to create again this is
another case where you are going to
create
more disease just like telling people
they shouldn't exercise outdoors alone
right you are going to create more
disease because they're going to do
something else
so you have to tell us what it is that
we are trying to optimize so that we can
operationalize it
rather than you know come up with some
overly simplistic idea like two masks
are better than one
where we can now start scowling at
people who are only wearing one mask
right that is destined to do harm and
the fact that
um that we we aren't having the
conversation right
right it's clear what the pattern is
you've got you had one mask
now we're being told to can we fast
forward and
find out what you're going to say about
three right we ought to know everyone
wants simple rubrics
and um especially because this is
confusing
and i would argue some of this is
intentionally confusing this is being
made more confusing than it need be for
reasons that
i will remain agnostic on for now
a friend of ours told me a story this
week that she experienced
several weeks ago in which she's in a
grocery store
and there's some dude with a you know
imperfectly fitted mask
who was on his phone the whole time
talking loudly through his phone when
therefore you know talking we
know spreads viral particles much more
than being quiet
talking loudly presumably because he's
talking through his mask
and he's picking up all this produce and
putting it down and yes film mites don't
seem to be a big cause
like you know most of us are trying to
be a lot more careful about not handling
a lot of stuff that we're not actually
going to buy
in store so he's picking up all his
produce and he's talking loudly on his
phone the whole time
and he's presumably his own little you
know if he if he was sick
he was spreading this stuff and so as
they happened to check out around the
same time and as she
was preparing to go out into the winter
weather she had to adjust something here
and briefly took off her mask in order
to get herself adjusted
and he walked by and saw her and voiced
a nasty snarky comment about how masks
are keeping us safe and why doesn't she
care
it was the guy who was behaving uh
despicably frankly yeah you're right
it's it's the simple rubric
it's the simple rubric problem the fact
that he was wearing a mask and behaving
in every single other way
badly with regard to how to reduce the
chances that if he were sick he was
going to get other people sick
didn't affect him at all it's like it
didn't enter into his world view
and he could still feel all high and
mighty whenever he sought
anyone who was for a moment doing the
one thing that we are told we all must
do if you care about your friends and
neighbors
so those of us who can think i think are
having a problem
with a complete failure to do any
net analysis right there is a sense that
um that which might help is
should be policy right well it might be
that somebody is going to catch the
virus from you outdoors while you're
exercising alone
so let's have you not do that with no
understanding that you will therefore do
something else where it's more likely to
get transmitted right
so the point is this is a at best
well-intended policy that is likely to
kill right
um i would argue that the two mask thing
is too
does that mean that most people's mask
choice wouldn't be better doubled
it might well be but we need to know
what we're optimizing
before we know whether or not we should
double our mask if you're wearing a mask
of one of those vents in it
i'd like you to double mask because
those masks the vents on them they don't
protect the rest of us at all
right like there are some masks that are
crap and no one should be wearing them
right right now here's another one to
add to the list okay
at the beginning of this i was waiting
for some sort of guidance
about the vaccine and people who had
already been sick with covet
right because there's an obvious
question here now let's take the most
basic level
okay people who have had covid have
effectively had a vaccine
to this version of covet right they have
been exposed to those proteins
that's what the immune system is that's
why they got better right the point is
the immune system figured out the plan
the dead ones the ones who died of coba
19 they have not effectively been
vaccinated
they were partially vaccinated but let's
just say if you recover if you actually
had it and you actually recovered the
point is your immune system figured it
out
now do we know that that will have the
same lasting immunity as the vaccine
no but we also don't know that the
vaccine has lasting immunity and there's
every reason to expect it because what
these vaccines so far
are doing is they are exposing the
immune system to the very spike protein
in order that when the virus actually
invades your system your immune system
already knows what it's looking at and
attacks it but here's the thing
so i was waiting for them to say look if
you've had
covid you at least shouldn't get the
vaccine early
there are multiple reasons for this one
is
you don't need to take the risk of the
vaccine the vaccine isn't just the spike
protein right
or the mrnas that will create it it's
also the
lipid nanoparticles it's also whatever
medium it's in
it's a lot of things and so why take the
risk if you've effectively had the
vaccine
that's one question then there's another
question which is how do these things
interact now it may be that some
immunologically very well-educated
person will have some answer to this i
don't see coming but here's the question
your immune system functions on the
basis that
your cells will be able to recognize
and attach to the
proteins for which they are targeted
right so you get spike protein into your
system
your system figures out the
electromagnetic sequences that result in
antibodies and or t cells being able to
stick to this thing
and that's how it works right now if you
get a vaccine right that generates
spike protein those spike proteins which
are not associated with virus
will stick to those cells and antibodies
that
are targeted at them there comes a point
at which you may
saturate those things and you may in
fact open the door to covid
because the point is your immune system
was busy dealing with particles that
weren't associated with virus
and that let virus get through you know
in some other way that is at least
plausible
right so now there has been guidance in
the last week or so
that says if you've had covid you should
get one
of the two vaccinations rather than two
right
so that is at least moving in the
direction of there's a question here but
my point is that question was on the
table from day one and even if
nothing else is true if it is the case
that this vaccine is as good as we think
it is
and as safe as people say it is then the
point is
the people who have had coveted would be
a lower priority
because they are already at least
somewhat vaccinated and therefore if the
idea is get the vaccine to as many
people as possible
the policy that says get the vaccine no
matter whether you've had covet or not
is going to kill people because it's
going to leave some people unprotected
so that's
it's again a problem simple rubrics and
that's exactly the third reason that i
was going to put on the table which you
just landed at
which is the third reason not to
prioritize getting the vaccine if you've
had coven 19
is that if we are being told the truth
and i believe we are in this regard
that we don't have enough supply and
that we are trying to distribute it as
the vaccines
as effectively and efficiently as
possible to the people who need it most
than the people who almost certainly
have onboard endogenous
endogenously generated immunity already
should not be first in line
for the vaccine yep there's if there's a
supply problem the people who
are particularly high risk from the
vaccine
um like people with autoimmune diseases
or i think pregnant women
and children um probably shouldn't be
first in line
and people who are likely already to
have immunity that they themselves
generated should not be first online
yep and i would say we can add another
reason
for uh for skepticism here at least for
the
already exposed or already infected with
covid once
crowd which is the way these vaccines
work the mrna is going to get into cells
it's going to cause the production of
spike proteins which are going to be
displayed by those cells i believe the
fate of those cells will then be that
they will be targeted
by t cells and killed or
they will have apoptosis programs
activated in other words
the body will deal with them like
they're infected with the virus
right so the point is you're killing
tissue that's not going to be good for
you either
so you know there are let's put it this
way a logical analysis
suggests that there are all sorts of
reasons that we should be doing a much
more nuanced job rather than just
wagging our finger at everybody and
saying everybody should get the vaccine
because vaccine good
right all right uh well
we're already well over an hour but
we've got um
a little cluster of topics that i really
want to spend a little bit we're just
getting started
yeah we're just getting started i said
to you today i think we're going to need
four hours to start doing our live
streams we're not going to do that but
um there's just so much all the time and
uh
you know i only got back through
february 10th in terms of my list of
you know topics that i was trying to get
to this week
um okay so the next three topics which
are broadly speaking
how the moon affect our sleep and other
cycles and how exogenous mood disruptors
are affecting the personality of fish
and what carnival is about are all
linked in my mind actually i was i was
playing with all of them and i think
how you know what they are they there is
actually a theme
running through these which is um
exactly the theme of our book a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
which is like how the ancient forces
that we evolved
in and with we might had ought to pay
attention to
and uh pretend that they are no longer
relevant to us at our peril
and also pay attention to the new forces
and technologies and such that we are
being handed
with a bit more skepticism like this is
just this
this is a fairly simple rubric actually
and you know say i who have been railing
against simple rubrics
um that the older it is and that we have
been evolving with it the more likely
it is not to cause new kinds of harm
it's not to say we couldn't do better
and that's not to say that that that
progress can't be made
uh but be the most cautious of the
newest stuff
with which we have the least history so
that's that's the
that's the kind of lesson there so um
i've told you about a little bit of
what's
what we're going to talk about here a
couple of articles came out
um this week i think or at least they
were reported on this week so
let us i'm going to just have you zach
just show very briefly
here's one of them this is uh kasaragi
at all 2021
uh moonstruck sleep synchronization of
human sleep with the moon cycle under
field conditions so um
may i have my screen back thank you um
i'll just read a little bit from the
results consistent with previous studies
shorter sleep duration and a delayed
onset onset of sleep were associated
with increased access to electric light
moreover both the duration and the time
of sleep onset showed a clear modulation
throughout the moon cycle that was
evident in the whole population
as well as in the individual communities
now this this
paper was was interesting and so anyway
which communities do they study
so they were i was just gonna go back
and look they looked at indigenous
i'm gonna mispronounce this i'm sure
toba slash
com q-o-m uh communities in argentina
uh where they've got so these these
these peoples
um live all in in all range of
conditions from sort of their original
hunter-gatherer-like conditions to fully
urban
and so they went and looked at if memory
serves and i i did not have
enough time to look at either of these
sleep papers i want to talk about today
a little bit um
they looked at um moon
stage and um sleep in
the most like the original indigenous
hunting gathering or without light
pollution
right very little fully urbanized
industrialized
and then a sort of an intermediate stage
that has some light pollution as well
and so they've effectively controlled
for a lot of stuff around culture
right um because it's all the same it's
it's all the same lineage
and they still even the industrialized
people i think are still
honoring some of their established um
uh cultural norms um but
what they found was uh that
uh i mean exact exactly as you would
expect if you if you've ever been
backpacking
or if you've ever thought about the fact
that we are evolved human beings on this
planet
um that we are cueing into the moon
and that when we have electric lights
that replace that effectively replace
the cues that we get from the moon
especially at night
we are less we are sleeping less we are
sleeping less well
um that absent electric lights this is
this is something
interesting i don't remember this is
from this article or if something that
they referenced in this article
that very rarely without electric lights
do people
people often go to bed after dark and
they may use fire they may use moonlight
they tend to go to bed later the more
full the moon is with a couple of
interesting exceptions like apparently i
think it was the hadza
who actually have explicit nighttime um
festivities on new moon nights
interestingly okay so you know they're
going to be exceptions but
um very rarely if ever
do people absent electric lights rise
before the sun rises
that going to bed after dark is common
but rising before the sun rises is not
and oh boy might that have something to
do with how much more sleep deprived
people feel
in the winter months and especially for
teenagers having to get up early when
it's still pitch
dark out rouse themselves from sleep
when we know that this is a time of life
when
people need more sleep and um and
rousing them when it's still dark out
and sending a signal
um that really until electric lights no
human beings were ever being sent
might be disruptive not just to sleep
that day but to sleep more broadly
and probably to the developing brain as
well okay so i still miss something
though okay so there's some sort of
synchrony with moon phase
which i would expect but what how does
it manifest what is it
when people go to bed is it how often
they wake up when they're sleeping what
kind of thing
um so there's less they sleep less
um when it's full oh so um
okay so there's there's two comparisons
that we're doing here and i was mostly
talking about the
the other one so the um sort of hunter
gatherer to
industrialize the more industrialized
you are the less in sync with the moon
phase you are
and the more destructive your sleep is
with regard to how does your sleep if
you are living without electric lights
how does your sleep change across the
moon cycle
people are trying to go to bed later
under full moon conditions
and under a full moon sleeping less per
night but
that is a you know predictable fairly
even
curve over time i've always wondered
about this because i have been kept up
by the moon
and it seems like we are very
we are uh well designed not to be kept
up
by uh fire light something we you and i
have talked about
uh a lot but um and you know for good
reason
you you would want it not to basically
be informing your pineal gland at what
time of
day it is because it's it doesn't
contain that information
right but the fact that the moon
which is reflecting obviously some light
somehow does keep you up if you're
sleeping in a circumstance where you
can't block out moonlight it's plenty to
keep you up
also interestingly uh many years ago
when i was doing
bat research in panama um i
was i can't remember exactly what i was
doing but i spent
a night at the top of one of these
canopy towers i think i was
waiting for there were some uh fruits
maturing there and i was hoping to
see fruit bats which didn't work out but
nonetheless
um oh i we should come back to why i
might not have seen the fruit bats it
has to do with something called lunar
phobia
that exists in bats but in any case
i discovered that i could read under
moonlight it was just
barely the right amount of light to read
uh which is interesting you know any
less you know
just slightly less than full moon
wouldn't be enough
so i don't know if that's haphazard or
not but yeah it's an interesting
connection
that is an interesting connection um
and so just a another um another paper
that came out recently that i had i was
able to spend even less time with so i'm
just really going to read a couple of
of sections from it is this um
forster at all and again you can show my
um my screen here zach
we show that women's just the second
half of the abstract we show that
women's menstrual cycles with a period
longer than 27 days
were intimate intermittently synchronous
with the moon's luminance and our
gravimetric cycles
with aging upon exposure to artificial
nocturnal light
menstrual cycles shortened and lost the
synchrony we hypothesized that in
ancient times
human reproductive behavior was
synchronous with the moon but that our
modern lifestyles have changed
reproductive physiology and behavior
and i'm just going to read the very
beginning of the introduction too
in many marine species and some
terrestrial species reproductive
behavior is synchronized with a
particular phase of the lunar cycle
generally the full or the new moon
this arrangement increases reproductive
success by synchronizing the
reproductive behavior of the individual
members of a species
in light of this fact is of interest
that the human menstrual cycle has
appeared close to that of the lunar
cycle and that several older studies
reported relation between the cycles
women whose cycles approach the 29 and a
half day period of the moon
have been reported to have the highest
likelihood to become pregnant
so that is you know it's the very
beginning of the article but i'd never
heard that before
but the closer the length of your cycle
is to that of the moon
the more fecund you appear to be um
super interesting
but really you know not surprising at
all
that our sleep cycles for all human
beings
and that for uh reproductively
women of reproductive age menstrual
cycles
are attuned to the moon in some way is
should not be surprising and to that end
i got to these two articles by reading a
this week in science short article
um which um
here zach um
the final oh
didn't like it i didn't like it when i
made it bigger okay
well okay never mind um the final
sentence is both studies stop short of
establishing causality but suggest that
even in highly industrialized societies
celestial bodies affect our bodies on
earth
yeah i think uh yeah it's pretty
interesting i do think the female
menstrual cycle and the
uh lunar phases are tightly connected
but
it does not require an actual effect of
the moon itself in other words there is
a mechanism for the moon
itself to to influence uh women this way
because they
you know under ancestral circumstances
would have you know
been monitoring effectively the the moon
phase but i don't think it's accidental
um that uh that close analogy
anyway maybe so so um yeah we should
definitely come back to this but you are
saying
um that this that the sleep work um
is of a different nature than the
menstrual cycle work
and that the menstrual cycle work may be
in fact
about a way that the human uh
body has figured out to basically keep
time yeah
uh keep time and awareness yeah that's
keep time keep a schedule keep an
internal schedule so that a woman
effectively you know in a species with
very few external indicators
of um of when we are at our most focused
um that if you can keep track of the
moon and
count to 29 um then you can do a decent
job
of um of knowing when you're fertile uh
yes and also
knowing when you are pregnant which may
be the most important
aspect of this which is that
in effect by if a woman's period has
accompanied a particular phase of the
moon
upon reaching that phase of the moon if
she is not near
her next period then she is at least
aware that there's something she has to
pay attention to which then
might have very uh deep implications for
her behavior because
um raising a child alone is uh
vastly dicier than raising a child with
a committed partner
yes so good okay yes let us let us do
come back to that yeah
um okay so uh this
article also came out this week
zachary um prozac turns guppies into
zombies
is the headline so this from science
news
and uh zach i'm sorry i need
i need this back just for a minute to
pull up the original research
and here we go psychoactive pollution
suppresses individual differences in
fish behavior uh
says crew pulverino at all um
and okay i'm sorry z i need thank you
um what do i want to read here okay the
first paragraph the introduction in the
last two decades the variety and
concentration of pharmaceuticals in the
environment has grown substantially
most pharmaceuticals including
psychoactive drugs such as
antipsychotics
and anxiolytics which is anti-anxiety
meds
and antidepressants are only partially
absorbed after ingestion
and once excreted are not fully removed
by wastewater treatment
such pollutants make their way into the
environment via wastewater remaining
biologically active in aquatic
ecosystems
as a result pollution by psychoactive
drugs is now ubiquitous in aquatic
ecosystems around the world
entering food webs and accumulating in
living organisms
and um again
see sorry i wish i had a printout that i
could read but i don't even know where
it went
um okay yes i was going to read the
whole abstract i guess
oh my god
environmental contamination by
pharmaceuticals is global substantially
altering crucial behaviors in animals
and impacting on their reproduction and
survival
a key question is whether the
consequences of these pollutants extend
beyond mean behavioral changes
restraining differences in behavior
between individuals i don't think i need
to read all of this
to understand the proximate mechanism of
underlying these changes we tested the
relative contribution of variation
within and between individuals to the
overall decline in individual variation
we found strong evidence that fluoxetine
which is the name of
prozac erodes variation in activity
between but not within individuals
revealing the hidden consequences of a
ubiquitous contaminant on phenotypic
variation in fish
which is likely to impair adaptive
potential to environmental change
in english that is
in english what that means is that
basically
fish are much
less likely to show
a wide variation from the mean of what
their personalities at the population
level
are if they've been exposed to even low
levels of prozac in the water
and apparently most water supplies in
most of the world are at this point a
wash in low levels of prozac which
is something that i actually did not
know the high levels of prozac in the
water
are going to be the case at basically
near your sewer outlets
but these low levels um actually render
these
they looked at guppies you know they
collected these guppies from one of the
few places i think it was australia
where there's really no prozac pollution
in the water and they put them in a lab
for i think it was six years
and exposed them to lab conditions in
which there was no fluoxetine low levels
of fluoxetine or high levels of
fluoxetine
and at both high and low they found
that these fish were just much more
likely to be average
than um you know behave like average
fish
than they did when they were not exposed
to prozac at all
and you know it i remember when prozac
was becoming a thing
right and this was you know this was
sort of the description it'd be like
well you expect your moods to be like
this
and some people's moods are way high and
way low we need to flatten it out and
it's just this
flattening you know this is this is the
really nasty flattening the curve
unlike what we're trying to do with
covid right and
you know maybe you don't want to flatten
people's moods so much that they cannot
actually experience and respond to the
insults and joys that life throws at
them and also
maybe the fact that this appears to
affect fish in the same way
suggests that we ought not be doing this
to you know
all of the vertebrates on the planet
including humans
yeah i mean obviously the
all moods good and bad are adaptations
you could be dysregulated in some way
that you're prone to certain moods and
away from others
but the chances that that is a
widespread problem rather than you live
in a
uh nonsense environment that's creating
anxiety because it's almost impossible
to navigate well
and therefore we're going to medicate
you out of recognizing that you're
actually imperiled every day by
you know a a cruddy world right that's
that's a non-solution and
you know okay so we're externalizing the
same garbage onto fish
that will of course mean all kinds of
things
one if you're taking these you know the
equivalent of fish moods
and flattening them those fish will not
do
as well as they would which means they
will end up preyed upon more frequently
failing to be properly motivated to
forage and
probably starve more frequently than
they would otherwise speed up the
extinction crisis right you're gonna
you're gonna contribute in some way to
to the extinction crisis um it is also
the case that you're now creating a
weird puzzle
for creatures more generally where some
creatures
are going to be intensely in the outflow
of this stuff and they will certainly
evolve to being less sensitive to it
right the less sensitive they are which
means that they will then experience
fish anxiety at the point that they
you know swim somewhere that it's less
concentrated so how does that work we
have an epidemic of angry guppies
right um which they could be very
i don't know nibbly or something but um
but yeah the you know
so the lesson is always the same
which is in nature knows what it's doing
and if you
disrupt it you are very unlikely to make
things better and very likely to make
things worse and
you know this should not be any shock to
us at all but it should give us pause i
mean for one thing
we're also downstream from all this
stuff even those of us who don't take
these things
are undoubtedly getting a certain amount
of it
um that we shouldn't be and uh you know
there's no way
to opt out yeah there's no way to opt
out and this observation
that um
this observation that it doesn't get
treated by wastewater treatment
like how is it that
a drug as widely used as prozac was
allowed to go to market when there was
no way to disable it
well i mean this is this is the story
everywhere is that you know
it's hard to put your finger on exactly
what the problem is going to be until
the entities that created this stuff are
so powerful that you can't tell them no
but this is one of our um this is one of
the
nights of our hanukkah tradition right
so so long time
viewers and listeners will know we've
talked about before and it's in fact the
epilogue of our book um the eight
for the eight nights of hanukkah we we
talk about one
thing that we think modern humans should
be living by and the one that i'm
referring to here i'm not going to have
the language quite right but
basically anything new that you put into
the world
you need to be able to undo before you
put it into the world all human activity
should be both sustainable and
reversible and reversible is there
because of this
uh this process whereby anything that's
economically profitable
becomes irreversible and that you know
so many you know everybody seems to know
that social media is driving us insane
right and yet
it's not even conceivable that we could
do anything like cut it out
right um you know that's not on the
table of solutions we're going to have
to
find enough band-aids to deal with the
insanity of the
entire human population rather than
realize we made a mistake and undo it
so yeah yeah so you know
in in the general scheme of things how
high does a narrowing of the spectrum of
personality types and guppies
rank as things you're concerned about i
expect um
no one at the end of today will be able
to uh say yeah that's
that's in my top 10. but as a horseman
as an indicator
of what it is that we're doing you know
in terms of effects that apparently no
one was thinking of
not only are we flattening whole swaths
of the human population with regard to
diversity personality types
this thing that we're letting them take
all of us are then getting some of it
and all the vertebrates who are in water
or who drink water are getting some of
it
and we're all affected because these are
ancient ancient
ancient receptors and it's affecting
everyone and it's
it is going to this is going to be one
tiny little parameter that is going to
affect things like the extinction crisis
because you get a you know you
effectively have a less diverse
behavioral repertoire in any population
and it's going to be able to deal with
change less well of course it will well
and
you know the irony of ironies which i'm
sure you're gonna end up speaking
about at some point uh at length on the
podcast is that the entire
hypothesis on which this pharmaceutical
solution was predicated it was
wrong to begin with and wasn't plausible
to begin with right the idea that
you know some large fraction of the
population is suffering from chemical
imbalances that need us to come in there
and
you know re-tune their reabsorption rate
of these things
doesn't make any sense it doesn't make
any sense anymore then
you know there's suddenly a genetic
crisis that is causing
children's jaws to be malformed relative
to their teeth
or we're a terrible species that happens
to rule the world oh my goodness so much
mutation that is just crept in and we
just
need medicine to save us from each and
every feature of our beings that is
coming apart genetically it's nonsense
yeah um so yeah now these drugs so we we
will at some point spend a long time
on this but yeah you have it in a
nutshell
um treating chemical imbalance very very
very rarely creating chemical imbalance
pretty much always
that's what they're doing yep that's
what these these neuroleptics and
antipsychotics and anti-anxiety and
anti-depression meds
are doing creating chemical imbalance
not resolving it
yes and in fish great
terrific all right carnival yes
wonderful wonderful topic so um
having you know i'm sure there's a
direct fish and sleep and moon angle but
um but really the theme again
is um you know what are those things
we've been doing for a long time and
what value do they have and
um is it dangerous or you know in some
cases like with cardaval it feels just
sad
that we're not doing it right now but it
might actually have
you know also long-term effects so
carnival should have started last night
um carnival um and it's b it's basically
cancelled it's at least subdued this
year so historically carnival
where everywhere everywhere so carnival
is always the same
timing because it is um and the american
form is mardi gras
even though that's obviously a french
term
um it is marked the days before lent it
begins the friday
uh before lent and goes through
wednesday ash wednesday and ash
wednesday is then always 46 days before
easter sunday so exactly when easter
sunday is varies and i
i don't know all the logic of what
decides that but ash wednesday is always
46 days before easter sunday and um
carnaval
or mardi gras um always begins the
friday before ash wednesday
so lent if we're going to talk about
carnival
i think we should talk about lent a
little bit first lent in many
christian traditions is a period of
spiritual reflection
and um penance is often paid
and repentance of sins is encouraged and
self-denial is a primary aspect it's the
one with which most of us
um who have not uh you know honored it
for whatever reason will be familiar
in which uh someone will give up
something that they find it difficult to
give up like you know you can't give up
chores for lent that's not that's
cheating
uh you have to right um so you know if
you if you
really enjoy wine you could uh give up
wine
but if wine really isn't your thing if
you try to give up wine also cheating
so self-denial is this primary
manifestation and also actually fasting
is as well and specifically various
forms of intermittent fasting what we
would call in modern times intermittent
fasting
yet another way in which the modern
world has like rediscovered an ancient
truth
something you know intermittent fasting
and longer forms of fasting are known
from almost
all the major religious traditions and
then we you know we let kellogg tell us
who
how to eat for most of the 20th century
and we got big and fat and
sloppy and now people are rediscovering
that oh actually if you take some time
off food on the regular you actually
might be healthier
hey guess what almost all the religious
traditions had a way of doing this
and no they didn't have the you know
dietary mechanisms by which it works and
we still
don't mostly either but that doesn't
mean it doesn't work so anyway that's
that's sort of what lent has been 46
days
um of of penance of spiritual reflection
of
self-denial and in order to sort of get
people on board with that
um i think and i actually don't know as
much about exactly the history of how it
started
carnival began uh specifically in
latin america um as the five days before
lent
begins and its release of breaking out
before the inward careful reflection
begins
um so i had when i was in college and i
was an
anthropology major i had this class in
brazilian culture and society
and um i actually i have now i've now
been to three different carnivals and
you and i have been to one
and we're going to show some pictures
from the one that we were at together
but
um the three carnavals that i was
depending on how you assess lucky or
unlucky enough to
to attend were all with study abroad
programs and
uh the first one was in chitra in panama
in 2009 for my very first study abroad
program the second one was just a day in
coca
in ecuador in 2014 and then we were
together in cuenca
in ecuador in 2016 for carnival
and in each of those cases it wasn't
that i was
trying to get my students to carnaval um
it's actually that in in latin america
so much of the rest of the world closes
down during carnival that it's very hard
to
get to a fee you know if you're if
you're not already at a field station um
it's very hard to move around and get
stuff done and so i sort of leaned into
it went well okay
we're doing this animal behavior work
and we're focusing a lot on human
behavior and
um and prehistory um early history
of humans in the americas and you know
behavior of contemporary animals and
including people so let's go do some
kind of cultural anthropology do you
know be ethnographers be participant
observers um at carnival and yes
um you know that means participate but
also
keep your observer hat on and so in
preparation
for that for my first time at carnevale
i went back i reconnected with my
professor from that brazilian culture
and society
class at uc santa cruz a man by the name
of dan linger
uh reached out to him about um
about carnival and how he understood it
he he specifically
has done a tremendous amount of work in
bahia in the atlantic
um tropical state of bahia and brazil
and he said that the three most salient
aspects of carnival
are these symbolic reversals of power
rituals of rebellion and which includes
critiques of the status quo
and inviting the liminal so like working
at the edges of consciousness
and you know trying trying to be in that
sort of shimmery place between
categories
uh where you feel like you might fall
off the edge or you might not you might
discover something if you fall and you
come back
and all of those i think so symbolic
reversals of power
rituals for rebellion and inviting the
liminal
can be manifest in a lot of what we see
in in some of the more formal aspects of
carnival
you know men dressed as under acting as
women
employee as employer and in the in the
older days
um slaves as slave owners like actual
reversals of power for just this very
short
period when it was acceptable young is
old these things are allowed
during carnival and we saw some
manifestations of this
these things are allowed within limits
of course right so
um in um just just to give you guys a
little bit more sense of it before
i show it or maybe we want to talk a
little bit first about our experience
but um
first um i want to read so as part of my
original class that i had in the early
90s we read
we watched the movie black orpheus which
is extraordinary
um which really you know shows um
brazilian carnival
i think it's from the 50s maybe and we
also read
uh what has become one of my favorite
books a jorge motto book
jorge amado called donaflore and her two
husbands
and somehow i cannot find my copy of it
but
um i did find a i had it
um i did find
a description of it here we go um not a
description of it just a very
sm brief excerpt from the very beginning
so this is from
um donoflora and her two husbands a
moral and amorous tale
vadinjo donaflora's first husband died
one sunday of carnaval
in the morning when dressed up like a
bahian woman he was dancing the samba
with the greatest enthusiasm in the
deuts de jour square
not far from his house he did not belong
to the group he had just joined it and
the company of four of his friends all
masquerading as bahianas
bahianas and they had come from a bar in
quebec where the whiskey flowed like
water at the expense of one moises alves
a cacao planter rich and open-handed the
group was accompanied by a small
well-rehearsed orchestra of guitars and
flutes
the four-string guitar was played by
carlinjos mascarenas
a tall skinny character famous in the
warehouses ah divine player
the men were got up as gypsies and the
girls of hungarian romanian peasants
never however had hungarian a romanian
or even a bulgarian or slovak swung her
hips the way they did
those brown girls and the flower of
their youth and cockatree
when vadinho the liveliest of the lot
saw the group come around the corner and
heard the skeleton-like mascarenas
strumming his sublime four-string guitar
he hurried forward and choses his
partner a heavily rouge romanian
a big one as monumental as the church
the church of saint francis for she was
a massive golden sequence and announced
here i come my russian from toronto
the gypsy mascarenas who was also
bedecked with glass beads and spangles
and had gaudy earrings hanging from his
ears pulsed his four-string guitar still
more sonorously
the flutes and spanish guitars groaned
and avatino took his place in the samba
with an exemplary enthusiasm he brought
to everything he did
except work he whirled in the middle of
the group
stomped in front of the mulatta
approached her in flourishes and belly
bumps
then suddenly gave a kind of horse moan
wobbled listed to one side
and fell to the ground a yellow slobber
drooling from his mouth on which the
grimace of death could not wholly
extinguish
the fatuous smile of the complete faker
he had always
been so that is
the very beginning of a book again that
i highly recommend uh
don't know flora and her two husbands
the second husband being the man she
will marry
later um this is this is uh
i won't say more about it it's it's just
a just a wonderful book
um so before we show some pictures and
maybe you know talk
over the the you don't know which photos
i've chosen but um
you know what photos you've taken um i
will say that
the first two carnivals that i went to i
was pretty disappointed and i have you
know i actually found
um an essay i wrote i found some of the
stuff that i had asked my students to
write about and some of them were just
brilliant in sort of
excavating what it was that they
expected and
teasing that apart from what we actually
saw and you know
the modern instantiations of carnaval
especially in chitra and panama and coca
in ecuador were really
just fire hose-fueled
foam-fueled beer-fueled
giant mad parties that didn't have much
to do with
this sort of symbolic reversals of power
and rituals of rebellion
and inviting the liminal in which a lot
can be learned
so it was a little bit disappointing but
then when we were back there during the
study abroad that we did together
in 2016 11 weeks we had our children
with us
we had 30 students um it was quite a
different scene
and and there was a different place too
it was cuenca um do you want to say
anything yeah well cuenca
is a colonial city and uh it's a
very beautiful and confluence of
five rivers four or five yeah in any
case it's a very interesting
place and somehow the carnival there has
largely though not completely escaped
the modernization that i think has
ruined it in so many
places but anyway i mean maybe the
pictures would be
useful a good place to to go okay hold
on i'm gonna find them
so oh come on um not yet
thank you okay so um
carniv the first night of carnival was
the knight of the grandfathers yes
uh and um and i just have one picture
from that and indeed all the rest of the
pictures i have are actually just from a
parade the next day so it's it's a it's
a sort of a narrow view
we we wandered the streets and
experienced a lot of carnival
of course one of the things about
carnival is with the reversals of power
having a very nice camera on the streets
in most places is not the thing you want
to do
so well in this case it's just an iphone
photo right but that's my point is that
most of
most of the wandering around that we did
um
we did not take pictures during because
um
we would have been inviting theft yep
um in any case this is a photo of a
police
band and so you'll see a certain amount
of foam flying around so people
during the the night of the the
grandfathers
and um during uh the parade
spray each other with this canned foam
and you know
it is sort of interesting here i think
um you can see in this photo
that the the police band is playing and
people are spraying
foam at the cops and everybody's taking
it in stride in a way that i think is
just
actually very hard to reconcile yourself
to given the tension with the police
in much of the west at the moment and
you know how healthy is this to have
this outlet
where you know the police and the the
other people of the town are
interacting in this way in which the
rules are temporarily suspended
the police are grinning they're smiling
they're like they're actually they
actually really do seem to be okay with
this and they
i it felt it feels like to me that i
remember
that there was even kind of a racial
component that on average the police are
a whiter
populous than um than the
larger population of cuenca anywhere at
least the people who were
approaching so there there was you know
there were reversals of power in a
number of ways you know people
spraying the police with foam people who
were often poorer and darker-skinned
spraying the police and the police just
playing on you know doing their doing
their mostly brass it was a brass band
as i remember yeah
yeah and then you know um i was pleased
to be able to get this shot this little
girl
is looking on and no doubt this is part
of how
she is coming to understand her world
and the police in it and you know that's
her experience watching the police
sprayed with foam playing
uh exuberant music is going to affect
the way she interacts with police
when things go back to normal after the
end of carnival
yes um so anyway you know we don't have
these healthy outlets we sort of somehow
uh bypassed them and how much harm
is there to the fact that we do and what
is it what what kind of harm is being
caused this year when apparently
carnival is really not happening oh true
you know
an annual outlet that people look
forward to and that prepares them to go
into lent
is extremely important actually
and it you know it can feel just like
festivities and boozing
if you've never been in it but to talk
to the people on the ground
many people actually look forward to it
rely on it
need it in a way that they may never be
able to explain but that doesn't
mean it's not needed so um
here we have a man uh with a with some
kind of facial
um stuff on i don't think that's old
foam i think he came sort of
decked out on this i'm just like
describing it for people who are
listening not sure uh he's wearing a
monkey skull around his neck
and he's holding two live roosters and
he's got um
ribbon around his neck as well yeah i
think he was actually an official of the
carnival parade i didn't quite catch
what his title was but
so i think i have 13 pictures here all
right uh
here we have a a man on stilts guy
is late to his appointment in the parade
and he he's
making up for lost time
uh yeah these uh traditional dancers
personal dancers in front of the
the big church there and there's there's
foam in the air like you can see
that that's there's actually foam in the
air yeah
you can buy these cans of foam
everywhere
uh and uh it really is a big part of
what what happens
is it's an outlet of its own
yeah people on their fancy motorcycles
again in front of the church you can
actually see there's a drone
in that shot somebody has a drone in
there oh there you go
yeah um so we wondered this was in 2016.
we wondered if this was perhaps the
first carnival where
uh where the drones existed people
weren't pleased with it
it came down low and i some someone
started throwing rocks at it and
i think it crashed into a building okay
yeah i i thought someone had been
throwing rocks on and then it also
crashed but
um so here you have confetti and the
drone and the church
um this is not a policeman but yeah guy
in a brass band has been
thoroughly covered in foam and is
continuing to play on
um different different kind of musicians
yeah
and a family again in front of the same
church and i
included this one in part because um you
also have
when you talk to people uh locals what
they look forward to most
often they'll say the food about about
the carnivale and cuenca and the stand
to the right here
they had roasted a whole pig and they
were making tortillas
and they had a whole bunch of salsas and
oh my god that was pretty good it was so
good
um here we have
just a family you know i think that the
man in the middle maybe all of them are
going to be participating in the parade
um but all bedecked the little girl has
a can of foam ready to
spray it at anyone who she thinks
deserves it yep these are indigenous
highlanders yep so cuenca is in the
andes uh i think this is the penultimate
picture
this is just a mother with her son on
her back
uh wearing what seems to be the
traditional fedora yeah
yeah um especially our valenos where the
fedora we're not in unavalo here it's
a long ways away but and then um
finally just an older cuencan couple not
bedecked not going to be participating
but you know eating plantanos or
something
from a bag and watching watching the
festivities yes if i recall correctly
they
they arrived at the parade holding hands
which i thought was
very nice given their advanced age yeah
so um
carnival is extraordinary and it's
pretty old
and people hold it in high esteem and in
cuenca a lot of people will stay for the
night the grandfathers and then go
to outlying villages because they find
that what happens in cuenca is too much
it's actually can be dangerous to be out
on the streets at night
but in the outlying villages it's even
more traditional we didn't do that
so we didn't see that but we had some
students who who went there with their
host families
um and and reported something
like that and i do you know
one of the very very very many
downstream effects
of this pandemic is the disruption to
regular and long-awaited events and that
you know the day-to-day is beginning
it has for many months but it's
beginning
to get really bad for a lot of people
and
for those of us in america most of us
don't have something like this
like five days every year that you can
rely on when it's going to be
where you are allowed to play around
with borders and categories in liminal
space
and just let it all out and it's more
honorable if you do that with the
expectation that you are then going to
go into a period of some privation
um in advance of you know whether or not
you believe in a christian god or not
but in advance of then
you know having it go back to normal you
know your life
as of eastern easter sunday um
i i've often felt since i started
attending
you know going to these carnivals that
we could use something like that and
i've never been to mardi gras but it has
never looked to me you know it looks
like a disney vacation of carnival from
a distance anyway
um but we we could use something like
this and right now none of the world is
getting it
and it's it's going to cause further
harm
mental health harm in a world that is
already
plenty sad so i think there are there
are two components here that i would
like to see
separated one is the failure of the west
to have a deep tool kit of such
traditions
which are likely necessary in order to
avoid certain things that i think we are
suffering
from uh very precipitously at the moment
and then the other is the disruption of
these traditions for
people who have them presumably the you
know weekly
uh dance that would occur in every one
of these
towns isn't happening either and so you
know we don't have that tradition
and i suspect that the but we've lived
in places in latin america where they
did and we've attended them occasionally
and it's you can just see how necessary
it is how important it is for people
well it's in particular deeply involved
in you know courting and so the idea is
there's some sort of
you know ritualized something in which
there are more or less rules and it's
taking place in public
and it is a strong counterpoint to the
derangement of the west over
those sorts of issues and you know
carnival is an annual thing
but likely the ability
to shift civilization gracefully
depends on having experimented with
these things rather than just like
suddenly instituting rules over how we
are to interact and what you can say and
what you can't say and what it means and
all of that stuff and so
um uh we
the absence of these things may end up
being a much larger piece of the story
of what happened to the west than than
we yet understand
yeah i think that's exactly right
well we have as predicted going on quite
a while
uh i think it has come time to make our
announcements and sign off all right
let's do that
let's do that so for those of you
watching we're going to take a 15-minute
break and we'll be back
with a live q a answering your super
chat questions
um you can become a dark horse member at
my patreon and get
access to that once a month two-hour
private q a
uh which we just posted a clip from
uh involving brett's first hatched
um crocodile um on both this main
youtube channel and the dark horse
podcast clips channel
um you have regular conversations
um for your um higher tier patrons
at your patreon there's nothing regular
about them except
for periodicity
you have no respect for time i
have a grudging respect for time yeah
you feel like you're under its thumb
and you're just you're fighting it oh
yeah
um so you can get uh you can get
darkhorse stuff
um including uh some with uh with
sayings like first against the wall club
and such at store.darkhorsepodcast.org
email our moderator darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com for logistical questions
and oh yeah and you're going to be on
the discord that you can get access to
either our patreons
tomorrow at 10 a.m pacific for a
breakfast with brett
bring your own hot sauce and
we have now uh gotten to the point where
i think um
dr rollergater is going to choose a
worthy person
and somehow you need to get your contact
info to him so he can get it to me and i
can get you an invite to clubhouse
um and uh maybe see you on there
yeah all right so as always uh be good
to each other
eat well get outside
and no more than six masks
all right all right be well everyone we
will see
you